[Music]
you'll be turning all shades of excited
for this week's picks including a Disney
and Pixar film getting a re-release in
theaters the return of a popular video
game based series Frankenstein in
teenager form the hottest sit come on TV
back for round three and a popular anime
flick has returned in 4k it's all coming
up on this week's what to watch
sponsored by Disney and pixars turning
red our ancestors had a mystical
connection with red pandas are you
kidding me this little Quirk runs in our
family
[Music]
getting its re-release in theaters this
week is Disney and Pixar's animated film
turning red this movie ended up
premiering on Disney Plus in March of
2022 and now it's finally getting its
theatrical release Here we are a couple
years later and this certified fresh
flick is finally getting its much
deserved time on the big screen speaking
of certified fresh at 95% on the Tomato
Meter the critics clearly love this
story about a 13-year-old girl on the
cusp of adolescence who keeps turning
into a giant red panda when she feels
any strong wrong emotions perhaps you
can relate no well the critic's
consensus calls it heartwarming humorous
beautifully animated and culturally
expansive so maybe you can relate to one
of those the cast for turning red is led
by Rosal Chang and sandre O as daughter
and mother respectively and it marked
the feature directorial debut for Dem
Mei making this the first Pixar film
solely directed by a woman we call that
groundbreaking oh and hey you might have
already caught soul in theaters But be
sure not to miss turning red and Disney
and Pixar's other re-release luk no
seriously don't miss them because check
out this promo if you buy a ticket to
each Pixar re-release turning red soul
and Luca you will get a buy two get to
offer for the upcoming Disney and Pixar
film inside out to one of the most
anticipated movies of the Year scan the
QR code on screen for more information
to buy your tickets to all of the Pixar
film fund now know that I am the
instrument of your
Extinction no that I am
returning to Paramount Plus for a second
season is the action series Halo based
on the popular video game and centering
around the cybernetically enhanced super
soldier Master Chief critics were
generally into the fresh first season
saying it showed glimmers of Promise
well now is the time to back up that
promise with a second season that
returns star Pablo shriber as Master
Chief along with Jen Taylor as Cortana
reprising her role from the video games
we love to see it and after a shocking
event at the end of season 1 involving
those two characters this new season not
only promises some interesting
Evolutions but it could also push our
boy Master Chief in line with his video
game routes maybe the hardcore Gamers
will be happy about it then doubtful
kidding does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he doesn't
play
sports I tenda is grave I talk to him I
wish I was been you coming to life in
theaters this week is the horror comedy
Lisa Frankenstein this film is inspired
by the 1818 novel Frank Frankenstein by
Mary Shelly and it's about a teen goth
girl in 1989 who resurrects a Victorian
era corpse so she can make him her dream
man the Lisa and this one is played by
Katherine Newton who you've seen in a
bunch of stuff including Ant-Man in the
was Quant Mania as Cassie Lang and her
Supporting Cast includes peeps like Cole
sprous and Carla Gino to name a couple
it was directed by Zelda Williams
daughter of the late Robin Williams in
her featurelength debut and making
things a little bit easier no doubt was
a script written by Diablo Cody who has
an Oscar in her trophy case for writing
Juno good day to the Fine teachers of
Abbot
Elementary what no comment about Gregory
being foi and fo no that is highly
inappropriate back for a third season is
the ABC sitcom Abbot Elementary this
show is coming in hot with two very
certified fresh Seasons under its belt
already and a whole bunch of amies and
Golden Globes to back it up series
Creator Quinta Brunson stars as a second
grade teacher at the show's fictional
black school in Philadelphia also Stars
along fan favorites like chery Lee Ralph
Janelle James Jes and Lisa and Walter
when it comes to new cast members we
know that Josh cigara from shows like
arrow and shehulk attorney at law is
joining the frey as a Philadelphia
School District representative D Manny
um does he know what he's in for can't
wait to find out to solve the mystery
and save
Humanity she must stop the dream
terrorists from altering our minds
hitting some theaters for a limited
re-release is the classic anime film PA
Rika this Japanese adult animated sci-fi
thriller comes from the late Satoshi
Khan an acclaimed anime filmmaker and is
based on the 1993 novel of the same name
it follows a detective and a therapist
who come together to stop evil forces
from terrorizing people's dreams this
fan favorite from 2006 is not only going
to see the inside of theaters with its
new 4k restoration it's also getting a
limited edition release in a steelbook
casing with special features and the
movie presented in Ultra HD paprika is
certified fresh on the Tomato Meter with
a high audience score as well critics
call it an eye-opening mind trip that is
difficult to follow but never fails to
Dazzle that's it for this week a solid
mix of options served up just for you no
need to thank us be sure to let us and
your fellow viewers know in the comments
what you did watch whether it was on
this list or not remember to check out
Ron tomatoes.com for the latest updates
on scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay
fresh